what exactly is McKinsey and Company
it's the world's top consulting firm it
serves 80 of the Fortune 100 companies
the McKenzie and Company's Client List
is full of Bad actors domestic
authoritarian foreign regimes communist
state-owned Enterprises they're given
the firm you represent he's played a not
so insignificant role in things like
opioid crisis they operate at the
expense of someone you know what would
your advice be to the 2000 workers that
are supposed to be terminated some of
the cost-cutting initiatives even quite
literally led to death as an Internet
tunnel A Train derailed and they must be
exposed at every opportunity
[Music]
10 billion in annual profit
control over 80 of the Fortune 100
companies and unparalleled influence
over the world's most powerful
governments
if I ask you to name
the most powerful companies in the world
some names right would probably spring
to mind uh Pfizer BlackRock Berkshire
Hathaway even the Umbrella Corporation
commitments honesty integrity
but what if I were to tell you that
you're missing one that there's another
company just as powerful just as big and
even more nefarious one with which my
very own team was actually lucky enough
to spend some personal time
why should we actually believe that two
representatives from McKinsey care about
the well-being of the American worker
[Music]
Health whether or not you want to take
what we've shared today as
helpful if that exchange seems a little
confusing you probably need a little
back story enter
McKinsey and Company
who are they what do they do the fact
that most of us have to ask that
question means that we are behind the
eight ball in a big way and
understanding the incredibly destructive
impact that McKinsey and Company
remember that name McKenzie and company
has inflicted upon the American people
so to grasp this let's start with the
front Okay the part that you probably
have think of a storefront stay with me
here a lot of it has been presented
under this guise of Consulting that's a
fun word anyone who spends time on
social media has likely seen one of
these day in the life videos from people
in the Consulting world
and it's thrust into your feed
mercilessly without your consent in a
life as a consultant in New York City
here we go start my day off with a
workout getting ready get a sandwich
packed kept pretty casual today for the
office this is the office again not many
people come in but that's okay quick
coffee break snack break then went in
this breakout room to kind of just get
some work done pray for my posture
please more snacks now to a meeting room
for a meeting to close the day out now
these videos are meant to romanticize
the Consulting I'll keep doing this
Consulting industry and attract
applicants from the nation's top
Business Schools they want you to think
that they're Consulting world is a lot
like this
one in reality the Consulting world
is more like this
crap sorry wrong clip I mean more like
this
yeah uh
bomb is a consultant
[Music]
in a nutshell consulting firms give
advice and direction to companies
focused entirely on maximizing
shareholder profits so that's the boring
part really at the end of the day
consulting firms are at best
professionally useless and at worst and
most likely actively destroying America
or the country you live in according to
a former Management Consultant who spoke
exclusively with our team here the way
it works is upper management will have a
pet project they're afraid to back so
they hire a consulting firm to push said
Pet Project consulting firms are then
hired to give the client what they want
at the end of the day ninety percent of
what Consultants provide is information
the business already knows Consultants
spend 50 percent of their time
justifying their existence to clients
which means they aren't really doing
anything fifty percent of the time just
a lot of waste and bloat now some of you
would say that that's a
mischaracterization fair so I would ask
you do these professional broads strike
you as useless so our Workforce is only
becoming more diverse inclusion is only
as only and more and so we really need
our people leaders to lean into this
it feels like artwork sometimes and
moving cultures is hard work
a lot of times the moving sort of I
think of as like microcultures right the
culture on your team the culture funny
project that we move a lot faster than
people often think or then people sort
of give a credit for so showing up a bit
different set of behaviors and
encouraging it in others can pretty
quickly move the meal for any
individual's experience the answer is
yes
we'll go back to those two lovely ladies
who happen to be partners for McKinsey
in a little bit but first what exactly
is McKinsey and Company why should you
care how does it affect you all right
it's the world's top consulting firm it
was founded in 1926 by James o McKenzie
it has 90 offices and 50 countries it
serves 80 of the Fortune 100 companies
as well as National governments that's
important we'll come back to that 10
billion dollars in annual profit that's
more than one million dollars per hour
and key McKenzie and Company alumni
include Arkansas Senator Tom Cotton
alphabet CEO that means Google and
YouTube sundarp and shy gross I threw up
in my mouth a little bit former meta CEO
Cheryl Sandberg that's formerly Facebook
and everyone's favorite resident gay
Pete Voodoo jage butt cake
so McKenzie and Company's Client List is
full of Bad actors domestic foreign
private and public you remember Purdue
Pharmaceuticals the company who actually
did play a role in the legitimate opioid
epidemic in the 2000s and I know that's
a third rail people have blown it out of
proportion but Purdue Oxycontin right
there was a problem McKinsey advise
consulted Purdue on how to increase the
sales of the Oxycontin pill right in the
middle of that epidemic it was Mackenzie
who advised the company how to sell high
dose pills even after Purdue
pleaded guilty to misleading regulators
and doctors now between 1999 and 2021
deaths involving opioid prescriptions
and this is important because I
understand that the opioid epidemic a
lot of it most of it has to do with
street drugs but opioid prescription
deaths Rose from less than 5 000 a year
to more than sixteen thousand per year
which is why in 2021
McKinsey settled to pay nearly 600
million dollars for their role in the
epidemic that's a lot of not
I don't want to focus on that so much as
the fact that there's a huge conflict of
interest McKinsey not only advises these
kinds of companies
but at the same time the regulatory
agencies that are supposed to be
overseeing them for example they were
advising Jewel on how to sell Vapes
you're an adult if you want to use a
jewel fine but they were also advising
the FDA on how to regulate vaping and
nicotine while collecting checks from
both agree for lack of a better word is
good and the part that really grinds my
gears or wood if I was in early 19th
century version of what we imagined a
robot to be is that McKinsey advises
authoritarian foreign regimes and
communist state-owned Enterprises an
example in 2016 McKinsey helped the
Saudi government
intimidate arrest and jail dissidents
McKinsey had prepared a nine page report
measuring the public perception of
certain Saudi economic policies and
cited three individuals who were driving
much of the largely negative coverage on
Twitter a Saudi arabia-based writer
named Khalid al-alkami a dis living in
Canada named Omar abdulaziz
and Anonymous writer
after the report was created Al El Kami
say that three times fast was arrested
and abdulaziz's Brothers Living in Saudi
Arabia were put in prison the anonymous
Twitter channel was shut down
abdulaziz also says that his brothers
friends Associates in Saudi Arabia have
been arrested and tortured including
electrocution waterboarding and his
younger brother may have even had his
teeth pulled out
now if that doesn't do it McKenzie has
also worked with Chinese state-owned
companies now when I say that what I
mean to say is the Communist Chinese
party they were working for a company
called China Communications construction
company and this is the company that did
a lot of work building the islands in
the South China see these artificial
islands that China is militarizing and
is making the South China Sea into
basically what could become a Chinese
Lake this is you know very much a
problem for U.S foreign policy for the
U.S Navy yet at the same time McKinsey
has also been doing consulting work for
the Pentagon and for the U.S Navy
McKenzie's Consulting contracts with the
federal government give it an Insider's
view of U.S military planning
intelligence and high-tech weapons
programs but the firm also advises
Chinese state-run Enterprises that have
supported beijing's Naval buildup in the
Pacific and played a key role in China's
efforts to extend its influence around
the world according to an NBC News
investigation
some official Chinese Representatives
weighed in on the report
ing by the way if you enjoy this you may
consider tuning in Monday through Friday
10 a.m Eastern right here on YouTube or
Rumble where we do a daily show
that covers the entire Spectrum but it's
a comedy show today's a little more
serious
now here's the issue you can serve the
American Consumer and and working man or
woman or Z or
the Saudi Arabian government or the
Communist Chinese party you can't serve
all of these Masters which Master is
more powerful which one is dangling a
bigger carrot and McKinsey and Company
as consultants
have potentially irreparably
wrecked the American middle class look
what you did you little jerk not to be
clear I'm I'm pro-business okay there's
nothing wrong with doing good business
or making a profit the difference is
that starting in the 1970s McKenzie and
Company focused exclusively on
shareholder profits with conflicts of
interest advise companies to hyper
concentrate management functions among
Elite Executives I'm the captain now and
production workers were also stripped of
basic managerial functions downsizing
happens but this wasn't the result of
Market forces business conditions or
even necessity but a new managerial
world view from the top down McKenzie
partner John Newman wrote about the new
business strategy in his Memoir saying
the process though Swift is not painless
since overhead expenses are typically 70
to 85 percent people related and most
savings come from Workforce reductions
cutting overhead does demand some
wrenching decisions
now when IBM took their Consulting into
account and decided to remove lifetime
employment the officials there asked gun
store owners near the headquarters to
close their shops while quote employees
absorbed the shock so a lot of jobs gone
forever that never come back right and
that hurts upward Mobility class
Mobility pay discrepancy but here's the
thing it hurts class Mobility
because of a company with a worldview
beholden to foreign governments who do
not believe in the value of class
Mobility according to the former
consultant who spoke with us exclusively
the mentality pushed by McKinsey at all
is definitely a contributing factor to
the demise of the middle class it pushed
the idea that you have these Uber
powerful CEOs commanding the entire firm
from the top and hollowed out the middle
management and this is a super important
Point okay
there's a big difference between
business owners small medium even large
business owners and CEOs CEOs may have
had nothing to do with starting a
company they may not own that company at
all they are installed glorified
managers and in the 1960s this was
largely recognized and CEOs made about
20 times more than basic lower end
production workers today
it's about 300 times more
and who played a large role in making
this fundamental shift
you guessed it over nearly a century of
work McKinsey they argue has been
instrumental in shaping parts of
American society from offshoring to
securitized debt to CEO compensation one
issue that is really troubling in this
country I think everyone would agree is
inequality McKenzie has contributed
mightily to that going back for instance
the 1950 when one of their Consultants
decided to look at how much Executives
were making versus how much the workers
were making and he concluded that well
the workers are catching up so maybe the
corporations ought to figure out ways to
pay the leaders more every year they
built on that more and more and more and
Executives that the gap between what the
leaders were making of Corporations and
the workers kept growing and growing and
growing over the years some of the
cost-cutting initiatives that have come
from McKenzie and Company have even
quite literally led to deaths in 1997
May Kinsey advised Disneyland California
to undertake a series of revisions in
its maintenance department including cut
the budget by a quarter cut the number
of Supervisors by half cut the number of
managers by a quarter move the majority
of Maintenance to the graveyard shift
and and here's the problem you can still
be pro-free Enterprise
and understand needing to streamline a
business while recognizing the
devastating effect on the American
middle class that has been inflicted by
companies who are setting out nebulous
arbitrary cut it by a quarter cut the
number of Supervisors by half even
though they don't understand the
business model and may never have set
foot on the grounds of said business but
are collecting money from all different
directions none of whom share the same
values there's a big difference that is
not free enterprise one former Disney
mechanic noted the issues that the
change is caused saying we could have
three rides down at any one time while
the park was open one time Indiana Jones
went down for a dead vehicle we
responded to that it was a computer
problem then Peter Pan goes down the
supervisor said go to Peter Pan leave
Indiana Jones alone when we got there
people were hanging in the air on Peter
Pan now for reference when hanging in
the air
onto a poorly maintained ride happy
thoughts do nothing and sometimes those
riots go wrong
you can clap as much as you want and
believe as strongly as you can a fairy
is not going to show up sprinkle some
dust and save you here's another example
September 2003 Disneyland's Big Thunder
Mountain malfunctioned injuring 10
people and unfortunately killing one
when a ride mechanic failed to tighten
two bolts on the wheel of a popular ride
at Disneyland and a manager failed to
check the work was done before signing
it off it would sit off a chain of
events that would lead to disaster with
multiple injuries and one Rider even
losing his life now OSHA blamed poor
safety protocols and poor training for
the rides malfunction the same protocols
to a direct result of McKenzie's
consultations this company who probably
has no business running a theme park
there's a former mechanic at the park he
described an interaction that he saw
between one of their supervisors and a
McKinsey representative that must have
been a fun day when the consultant asked
why the mechanics bothered checking the
lap bars on Big Thunder daily when
records showed that they had never
failed the supervisor reacted with
disbelief the reason they don't fail he
said is because we checked them every
night let's contrast the McKinsey and
Company representative versus a business
owner the business owner might ask his
employee if it is his own business hey
why don't we do it this way can we
automate it if the employee says
actually the reason we haven't had any
failures is because this system ensures
safety oh great I don't want anyone to
die it's my business and I probably
won't have any more customers there is
no accountability connection or
incentive long term for McKinsey and
Company to look out for this company
that person more than the next company
or communist government that's not free
enterprise and the biggest issue with
firms like McKenzie is the Elites in
their ranks are they're so far removed
from the consequences of their
Consulting that they don't really have
sympathy for real world outcomes the
late Steve Jobs understood this
all too well and he was a fruitarian so
how many people Consulting
oh that's bad
you should do something by the way quick
note uh McKenzie and Company obviously
has their claws probably
right if you're watching on YouTube I'd
recommend going to rumble but leave a
comment or share this hit like it helps
with the algorithm okay uphill battle no
matter where you go now that we're all
caught up on what a piece of
company I use that word Loosely McKinsey
is let's rewind a little a little bit
so our Workforce is only becoming
more diverse
and so we really need our people leaders
to lean into this now these two handsome
individuals are Diana Ellsworth and
Monet spelled with two ends Williams
both self-proclaimed members of the
lgbtq plus rated Community Diana is a
partner at McKenzie's Atlanta office
according to her company profile Diana
leads McKenzie's diversity equity and
inclusion work Dei familiar with it
directs initiatives focused on
establishing inclusive productive
workplace cultures that support greater
collaboration and Innovation from a
diverse Workforce remember earlier with
that quote I said seemed benign who
determines
what's considered a positive impact
what change are we actually seeing
here's some titles for posts that Diana
herself has authored on McKenzie's
website they include racial and ethnic
equity in U.S higher education students
and faculty no word on what they do with
Asians racial and ethnic equity in U.S
higher education why women of color are
leaving and how to rethink your d-e-n-i
strategy again if a giant all-powerful
Corporation determines that focusing on
Equity is positive change then you can't
have equality
equality or Equity you have to pick one
equality means equality of opportunity
Equity means ensuring outcomes based on
race based on sex based on gender
friction whatever we're considering
today but she does sound granted like a
lot of fun at parties now her colleague
Monet spelled with two ends and I'm
getting very near the end of this now is
no less Progressive she is also at the
Atlanta office where she is quote
helping clients Drive mindset and
behavior change and build capabilities
at scale among her highlights Monet
spelled with two ends hosted a webinar
for the company called Equity there's
that word again and a path forward for
black employees
interesting point of topic given the
fact that the average McKinsey and
Company partner like Monet spelled with
two ends earns on average 560 thousand
dollars also a path forward for black
employees call me traditional or racist
here should be the same as for any
employee show up on time do your job
well make the company better and help
your teammate slash fellow employees I
don't know why melanin should be the
determining Factor but McKinsey and
Company does believe that's the case and
they want to ensure that every company
follows lockstep because hey that's a
positive change isn't that Monet spelled
with two ends so when it comes to
advancing the rights of the world's most
downtrodden which changes at any given
day writing the wrongs of white CIS men
that category stays the same for all
time these ladies are Aces they're tops
but how would they handle you know
actual questions kind of like a
consultant handling an actual ride at
amusement park start with the McKinsey
spokeswomen are both notably openly
lesbian and that is an accomplishment
for which they should be proud and no
one can ever take it away from you let's
see how they do when asked about doing
business with countries that kill
lesbians
how much overlap do you have with
mckinsey's ethics or values given that
it partners with like the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia it's highly illegal to be a
member of the lgbtq community there and
if you chose to engage in supporting
that Community would you face backlash
with your company so I think it's a fair
question and I think a lot of us have to
figure out the degree to which we feel
like we fully align with the place that
we work I think you know for me I
believe our firm is really committed to
a lot of things that I am also really
committed to I think on the you know you
conveniently or coincidentally have two
members of the lgbtq plus Community as
your speakers today I'll say very
candidly when I actually joined our
Atlanta office
there was nobody out in the office uh
there were no out consultants in our
office at the time there were actually
no out Consultants at the time in what
we called our Southern office it was
Atlanta Charlotte Houston Dallas and
Miami
um and it almost was the reason I didn't
join the firm uh because it seemed kind
of concerning to me sure you mentioned
passion for helping that community in
your life outside of work what career
impacts might you have
if you chose to do that for people
living in Saudi Arabia or Dubai
is from a really committed
co-lead our Global lgbtq plus affinity
group and it's a Global Group we have
folks in all of our offices we have set
up a system where we have different
levels of membership and different sort
of degrees of outness but it is a it's a
global Community that's sort of
consistently growing we have a number of
offices that I've been at the firm 14
years now or in a dramatically different
place today than they were when I joined
in terms of uh the number of out
colleagues and and how folks engage but
it's the firm is I mean supportive of
the community
Full Stop in all of our global locations
and sort of all of our offices
regardless of the broader political
context in which those offices exist
she admitted that she has been with the
company for 14 years Saudi Arabia
imprisoned people on McKinsey and
companies advice only five years ago if
14 years ago her and her friends laid
foot in Saudi Arabia it would be
reigning Butch men for a week now let's
see how these Geniuses handle but
lesbians for which they should be
certainly proud and no one can take that
away from them see how they handle
addressing the sins that their company
has committed in the name
of turning around a quick profit I think
a lot of the things you said today sound
great and I think we can all agree that
eliminating burnout is probably good for
most workers but not to be too hyper
critical but given the firm you
represent has played a not so
insignificant role in things like the
opioid crisis uh addiction for teens
with vaping and tobacco as well as the
hollowing out of America's middle class
and work with totalitarian regimes in
China Saudi Arabia places like that
why should we actually believe that two
representatives from McKinsey care about
the well-being of the American worker
I think you'll have to decide for
yourself whether or not you want to take
what we've shared today as helpful or
not uh
I'm Diana this is Monet and McKenzie
says things but the results are not
helpful not for jobs in Ohio
I know there's been a lot of press
recently I think we're not in a position
to be sort of the experts to comment on
everything that's there uh
our firm is created an incredible number
of jobs to the work that we do we
actually do more growth oriented work
uh
then we do the opposite and so on on the
whole
I firmly believe that we're in a better
place
because of the work that we do
we called it a
um
well
it may be comforting to know that they
care just as little about their own
employees as they do about you talking
about like burnout and like maintaining
a healthy life important balance what
would your advice be to the 2000 workers
that are supposed to be terminated by
your company as a pro part of project
Magnolia like what would you give to
them as advice
that's what every year in a row for five
years we've I have been laid off too so
it's a terrible thing what the
billionaires of the United States have
decided to do with that country well
it's not the billionaires it is also the
representatives and the people here
at first glance the panelists as well as
the entire crowd look as though
they were floored with a fence here's
the thing as is often the case
even in their own camp
you right now watch it you're not alone
not everyone there was displeased
with this team's approach thank you for
talking about it I just it's hard to
hear them yeah preach these things and
come and talk down to people yeah when
they don't care like their company yeah
it's um
respectful way people need to hear I'm
not trying to like be a provocateur I'm
just trying to get a real answer because
they never give a real answer no you're
not and I don't think people understand
the scope of what Mackenzie has done to
people over the past decades yeah anyway
thanks sir thanks for saying it but
those people
aren't really hurt
are they those people aren't interesting
to McKinsey and Company as a matter of
fact the respondents by the way who are
lesbian and should be proud and that can
never be taken away from them their
approach to handling even the most basic
questions
is kind of the perfect encapsulation of
not only the consultant class but
specifically the elite at McKinsey and
Company they're unbelievably well-versed
at screaming platitudes virtue signaling
but they have no interest in benefiting
anyone anything but their checkbooks or
their shareholders and to be clear
there's nothing wrong with shareholders
equities have made probably more
millionaires than any other device in
the history of mankind the problem is
when you create a company that isn't
really a company but exists solely to
perform for shareholders at the expense
of the consumer as well as the company
that is designed to serve the consumer
that is not capitalism if a CEO who
wasn't there for the founding of a
company answers to McKinsey and Company
to find themselves getting a big fat
bonus while their employees are being
laid off that is not free enterprise if
McKinsey and Company decides that it's
more profitable for their shareholders
for them to play ball with communist
China than to serve the United States
citizenry that is not free enterprise
this is not about being anti-business
this is this is about saving business
this is about saving American Ingenuity
and not just the American worker the
American business owner from the Hawks
like McKenzie and Company who very often
create no products themselves create no
businesses themselves they come in to
destroy a body and pick up the carcass
for a select few while the rest of you
the American public largely but
obviously citizens of other countries
I'm sure that the
citizens under the rule of communist
China or the gays in Saudi Arabia aren't
big fans of it either
are left to pick at the scraps these
giant Corporation government
amalgamations I'm not going to use the
word businesses deserve no respect
McKenzie and Company deserves no quarter
and they must be exposed at every
opportunity you've heard of BlackRock
you've heard of Vanguard they're
important because they operate
at the expense of someone you know
and it could just as easily and very
likely is you
people were losing jobs All Over America
and McKinsey was beating the drums on
this they are everywhere in DC
mckinsey's very influential in Western
Europe they have been for half a century
behind President Vladimir Putin's War
Machine against Ukraine sits rostek a
massive weapons maker it's controlled by
the Kremlin and until recently a client
of a leading American consulting firm
McKinsey and Company McKenzie advised
Purdue how to avoid FDA and Pharmacy
restrictions because McKenzie knew that
people were overdosing and dying clearly
McKinsey should not be setting strategy
for both drug companies and the FDA they
know exactly what the repercussions are
going to be and then they say we're
going to do it anyway and that tells you
all you need to know about the firm
[Music]